jeremy renner is a talented  oscar-nominated actor who really seems  intent on becoming an action star the  Avengers ghost Protocol Bourne Legacy  now Hansel and Gretel witch hunters I  gotta say if this film honors its R  rating I think we're gonna be in for one  hell of a ride every time I watch this  trailer I immediately want to watch this  movie I want to go witch hunting q photo  of Casey Anthony it just looks like pure  entertainment it's overblown with  violence special effects and it clearly  has a sense of humor about itself which  a film like this really needs overall I  gotta say hazlit Gretel witch hunters  could get it right